- As a drummer,
you're conducting not only the orchestra
that is the band on stage,
but the orchestra that are
the people in the audience.
That audience relationship
was a driving factor
around why I pursued music so vehemently,
and why I gladly spent my time
as a broke musician (laughs).
But that's not sustainable.
We need artists; we need artists.
When I discovered Blockchain technologies,
it dawned on me that this
could empower artists
to continue to share their
creativity with the world,
which is an invaluable human resource.
(music)
I played my first paying gig at age 14.
I became so obsessed with playing drums
and taking as many gigs as I could.
It fed my soul, it fed my, it's
kind of cliche to say that,
but it fed my creative spirit.
I was behind that drum kit
on various stages all over the world.
Shows where the applause from the audience
drowned out my thoughts.
I was signed to an independent label,
and I'm getting millions of streams
on digital distribution platforms.
I felt that I had made it,
and yet, I was still
struggling to make ends meet.
(music cuts out)
Where the money is for artists
is in live performances,
but when it comes to event ticketing,
there's still a lot of
unnecessary middlemen.
We often call them scalpers or touts.
These people buy up
roughly 60 percent of tickets,
and then charge these exorbitant markups,
and sometimes unsuspecting fans
show up at the door of the
venue, and they can't get in.
It's a fake ticket.
So it's a major problem.
- Just as the internet changed
the way we communicate,
Blockchain is going to
change the way we transact.
- [Jason] For the first
time in human history,
there's this technology
that shackles the brokers and scalpers.
- [Raphael] Blockchain allows
for direct transactions
between the artist and the fan.
- And the fan knows that
the ticket is verified
and authentic, and the
money will go directly
into the pocket of that artist.
- They're not adding any
value; get out of the way.
The fundamental design of Blockchain
is you have a peer-to-peer network,
so I can do this transaction
directly with you,
and trust that it's
real, and you know what?
I'm excited to go see the concert.
- The Blockchain is open,
transparent and immutable.
Anyone can go to a website and
see the transactions happen,
whereby it's incredibly
hard to change a transaction
once it has occurred.
Transparency creates trust,
trust forms the basis of community.
- The real human truth about Blockchain
is it's not just about changing
the way we transact money.
It's about leveraging the
technology’s shared record of truth
to establish trust between people,
companies or even nations,
and exchange what we value,
which is the whole point of a community.
- The human experience is tribal,
and live experiences cannot
be digitally replicated.
When the music hits you,
it's something very real and
visceral and non-digital.
It is just an incredible feeling.
(upbeat music)
Music is inextricably a part of who I am.
Because when it all comes crumbling down,
we'll still have song
and dance around a fire,
we're still gonna tell stories.
It's part of the human experience,
and without it, we'd just be
a bunch of ones and zeroes.
(laughs)
(electric guitar playing)